yeah it's the worst it's like i can't
get like one thank god for natalie
natalie natalie would be natalie is here
i think natalie look at she's she's
multitasking she's looking at her phone
and i saw her give herself like uh when
we walked in hell he's like please for
the love of [ __ ] do not bring me in
there so
i gotta make sure she stays out there
you love [ __ ] for the love of [ __ ] is
that why she's out there yeah i find
natalie amazing that is the best
but tell me the uh the real uh
relationship were you like childhood
friends
yeah so i i uh in the fourth grade we
kind of like met and i was great yeah so
now she works with me so now she works
we actually don't really know her title
i'm not allowed to say assistant anymore
it's something like more powerful like
cfo or ceo whatever it is why don't you
let her make her own time right what did
she give her a title because it was she
natalie she was like what is your title
come to the mic you don't have to come
in the room she doesn't want to come to
the mic she's not coming to no right
right there
just call her boss yeah
i am the president of david dobrego
she put on those glasses even to say it
yeah she wasn't wearing glasses she's
just sitting back looking at it but she
put on glasses she looks like a c f-o or
c-o-o she said president president yeah
i met her in the fourth grade and i had
like a really big crush on her like from
afar but then when i got to know her we
were just friends and then i had a
question wait that doesn't sound
positive for me
from afar i liked her and i was swooning
and then i met her and i went [ __ ] it no
i'll work with you i'm swimming
no it was we were pulling up um to look
at the house for the first time and she
was getting the mail because she was my
next-door neighbor and this is the first
time i saw my new home and the first
time i saw natalie and i was like who is
that beautiful girl i was obsessed i was
like in the third or fourth grade and
this was like maybe the first girl that
i've like actually had a crush on and
then i and then like a couple months
later i found out it was natalie who had
like gotten to know in school and i was
like what the [ __ ] was i thinking um but
now we're just really good friends
that's not coming off good no it is
we're totally cool with it now right
matt
does that come off good natalie what the
[ __ ] was i thinking
are you okay with that natalie
you know at this point i just kind of
take what i can get
beautiful girl i'll tell you that she is
a beautiful girl but not only beautiful
she does run he relies no she's she's
really good she is she models too oh
yeah she's sports illustrator she's a
sports illustrated model
she wears so many hats
was she on the boat with you yep yep she
was a weapon too what is that what she
was she's a weapon so we had a bunch of
david's friends bail they actually had
to get on another boat to be evacuated
nat stayed out there the whole time even
though she got sick she got in the water
had the best time she stuck through it
and got through she's really good at
that she's really just like [ __ ] it like
i'm already here i'm gonna get this done
like she's like would she put her period
blood on her face that's a good question
nah would you
she's shaking her ass but i can't hear
her
i don't think so
can i ask a question you were talking
about thinking and overthinking and one
of the things you said and maybe it was
normal to howie and everybody else
wow [ __ ] right in the middle
it's a wall of natalie wow
natalie lou took all these photos that's
when she takes her glasses off oh my god
look that's the president
president of david dobrik oh my god it's
like clark kent superman take those
glasses off as she turns into that last
even before i saw the pictures i thought
she was beautiful
i know what you're looking for a happy
ending
well he said he said earlier that she
wears a lot of hats i don't see one
[ __ ] hat on
[Music]